THEY DON'T MENTION IMPEACHMENT.
THEY USE ON USE UNELECTED
BUREAUCRATS WITH GUNS TO CROSS
THE PRESIDENCY.
THE WORST PART IS THAT IT'S
WORKING.
BYRON YORK FOR THE
"WASHINGTON EXAMINER."
JONATHAN TURLEY, THEY BOTH JOIN
US TONIGHT.
PROFESSOR, FIRST TO YOU, WHY NOT
JUST SAY WE WANT TO IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT, WE THINK WE'VE
COMMITTED HIGH TIME, CRIMES AND
MISDEMEANORS, THEY DO THINK
THAT.
WHY SHOULD THAT BE EMBARRASSING,
IT'S A CONSTITUTIONAL PROCEDURE?
>> THEY CERTAINLY SHOULD BE OPEN
ABOUT IT IF THAT IS THEIR
MOTIVATION.
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT THE
PREFERRED ROUTE FOR THE
CONSTITUTION IS TO HAVE A TRIAL
IN THE SENATE AFTER IMPEACHMENT
IN THE HOUSE, TO HAVE THAT
DECISION.
YOU CAN ALWAYS STILL IMPEACH
SOMEONE ONCE THEY ARE REMOVED
FROM OFFICE.
THERE IS AN ONGOING ACADEMIC
DEBATE WHETHER ANY SITTING
PRESIDENT CAN BE INDICTED BUT
MOST PROSECUTORS YIELD TO THE
IMPEACHMENT PROCESS.
>> Tucker: THERE'S NO DEBATE
OVER WHAT'S THE MOST DEMOCRATIC
MECHANISM FOR DEALING WITH THE
PRESIDENT WHO'S DONE SOMETHING
WRONG, IT'S BY USING THE
REPRESENTATIVE THAT VOTERS
ELECTED, CORRECT?
>> THAT'S THE PREFERRED WAY.
THE FACT IS THAT THE FRAMERS
GAVE US A PROCESS BY WHICH WE
COULD FIRST IMPEACH AND THEN
REMOVE THE PRESIDENT.
AS LONG AS YOU CAN PROVE HIGH
CRIMES AND MISDEMEANORS, CLEARLY
SOME DEMOCRATIC MEMBERS ARE
RUNNING ON THAT.
I DON'T SEE THE PROBLEM, FRANKLY
WITH TRUMP ALSO RUNNING ON THAT.
I THINK FOR HIM TO SAY THIS IS
ABOUT MY IMPEACHMENT, I HAVE NO
PROBLEM WITH THAT BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY THAT IS AN UNDERLYING
NARRATIVE FOR THE OTHER SIDE.
BUT I THINK WHAT WILL HAVE TO
HAPPEN FIRST IS MUELLER WILL
HAVE TO ISSUE A REPORT AND THEN
IF CONGRESS CHANGES HANDS,
PARTICULARLY IN THE HOUSE, YOU
COULD VERY WELL SEE THE
IMPEACHMENT PROCESS.
>> Tucker: THE QUESTION OF THE
SUBPOENA, WE SAW YET ANOTHER
PIECE OF INFORMATION LEAKED IN
THE PRESS RECENTLY THAT THE
MUELLER PEOPLE ARE CONSIDERING
SUBPOENAING A PRESIDENT.
AT THE WHITE HOUSE IS SAYING WE
MAY REJECT THAT.
WHERE DOES IT STAND?
>> THAT'S WHERE IT STANDS RIGHT
NOW.
WE DON'T KNOW IF MUELLER IS
REALLY GOING TO DO THIS.
WE HAVE NEVER HAD THIS COME TO A
CONFLICT IN HISTORY.
THE NIXON CASE WAS ABOUT
SUBPOENAING DOCUMENTS ABOUT
EVIDENCE, NOT ACTUALLY TESTIMONY
EVIDENCE, NOT ACTUALLY TESTIMON
TESTIMONY.
WITH BILL CLINTON, KEN STARR
SUBPOENAED BILL CLINTON AND THEN
THEY WORK SOMETHING OUT SO THAT
KEN STARR WOULD WITHDRAW THE
SUBPOENA WHILE BILL CLINTON
TESTIFIED, BUT HE DID GET A FEW
THINGS THAT YOU WOULD NOT GET
IT, HE GOT TO KEEP HIS LAWYERS
IN THE ROOM WITH HIM.
IF HE DID IT ON VIDEO.
HE DIDN'T GO TO A GRAND JURY
ROOM, AND THE TIME WAS LIMITED.
ON THE OTHER HAND, HE ACTUALLY
DID TESTIFY.
I THINK WHAT YOU ARE SEEING
RIGHT NOW WITH THIS CASE IS THAT
TRUMP IS REALIZED, PERHAPS THAT
THIS IS MORE OF A POLITICAL
FIGHT, THIS IS AN IMPEACHMENT
FIGHT MORE THAN ANYTHING.
WHILE HIS LAWYERS TALKED ABOUT
WHETHER A PRESIDENT CAN OR
CANNOT BE SUBPOENAED OR CALLED
TO TESTIFY, RUDY GIULIANI, WHO
IS REALLY MORE OF A SPOKESMAN
RIGHT NOW, AND OTHERS, ARE
WORKING TO DISCREDIT THE
INDEPENDENT COUNSEL, OR THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL IN THIS CASE
BECAUSE IF IT DOES COME TO THE
HOUSE -- BY THE WAY, THE REASONS
DEMOCRATS ARE DOING THIS IS
BECAUSE THEY ARE A MINORITY.
>> Tucker: THEY ARE ALSO NOT
TALKING ABOUT IT, MOST OF THEM.
SOME FRINGE MEMBERS ARE.
>> WERE MEMBER THE 2006 EXAMPLE
WHEN GEORGE W. BUSH'S NUMBERS
WERE JUST TERRIBLE.
THE IRAQ WAR WAS GOING TERRIBLY.
THE DEMOCRATS WERE RUNNING TO
TRY TO WIN BACK CONGRESS IN
THOSE MIDTERMS.
A LOT OF DEMOCRATS WERE TALKING
ABOUT IMPEACHMENT, BUT THE
PUBLIC REALLY DIDN'T WANT IT.
NANCY PELOSI CAME OUT ABOUT THIS
TIME OF THE YEAR IN 2006 AND
SAID IMPEACHMENT IS OFF THE
TABLE.
TODAY, 71% OF DEMOCRATS IN A
RECENT POLL SAID THEY WANT TO
SEE TRUMP IMPEACHED IF DEMOCRATS
TAKE THE HOUSE.
THE LEADERS KNOW THAT.
>> Tucker: THAT'S WHY IT'S SO
DISINGENUOUS TO DENY IT.
IF YOU ARE RUNNING THE
PRESIDENT'S LEGAL TEAM, AND YOU
SHOULD BE, I WOULD SAY, WOULD
YOU ALLOW HIM TO SPEAK TO ANYONE
FROM ROBERT MUELLER'S
INVESTIGATION?
>> THAT'S A TOUGH QUESTION, BUT
I ACTUALLY THINK THAT HE SHOULD
HAVE TAKEN THE DEAL TO GO SOME
TIME AGO AND SAT DOWN.
I WROTE A COLUMN MONTHS AGO THAT
SAID IT'S A GOOD DEAL IF THEY
STICK WITH THE FOUR CATEGORIES
THAT DOWD AND TY COBB NEGOTIATED
THAT DOWD AND TY COBB NEGOTIATE
NEGOTIATED.
COULD YOU PREPARE THE PRESIDENT
FOR THAT?
I THINK YOU COULD.
I THINK THAT WAS THE QUICKEST
WAY TO DEFUSE THIS.
THE QUESTION IS REALLY THE END
GAME.
IF YOU BASICALLY DEFY THE
SUBPOENA, I THINK THAT HE WILL
LOSE.
THE EXISTING CASE LAW FAVORS
MUELLER AND ONCE HE WINS IN THAT
PROCESS YOU GIVE HIM A COURT
ORDER WHERE YOU CAN NEGOTIATE
WITH HIM BUT HE'S IN A MUCH
STRONGER POSITION.
HE COULD DEMAND AND A COURT
COULD VERY WELL GO ALONG WITH
THE CONVENTIONAL GRAND JURY
THE QUESTION IS WHAT IS THE END
GAME THAT YOU ARE TRYING TO LAY
OUT?
I PERSONALLY BELIEVE THE
PRESIDENT -- PEOPLE KEEP ON
SAYING HE'S GOING TO BE A
DISASTER, HE'S GOING TO BURST
INTO FLAMES.
I DISAGREE WITH THAT.
I'VE DONE A LOT OF DEPOSITIONS
THAT WERE MORE COMPLICATED THAN
THIS AND I THINK YOU COULD
PREPARE THIS PRESIDENT FOR THIS.
>> TRUMP HAS DONE A LOT OF
DEPOSITIONS HIMSELF BURIED >> HE
HAS AN EXPERIENCE ON SIDE.
>> Tucker: VERY PRECISE PEOPLE
HAVE GONE TO JAIL HAVING FALLEN
INTO PERJURY TRAPS BY EXPERTS.
>> THAT'S TRUE.
THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT IT.